estado de emergencia en Nueva York
decretó el alcalde Erick Adams a través
de una orden ejecutiva tras la llegada
masiva de migrantes desde la frontera
sur del país
Netflix
esta orden ejecutiva ordenará
formalmente a todos los organismos
pertinentes que coordinen sus esfuerzos
para construir los centros de ayuda
humanitaria a la vez que suspenderá
ciertos requisitos de uso del suelo para
acelerar este proceso
la ciudad gastará mil millones de
dólares para gestionar la afluencia de
solicitantes de asilo desde principios
de septiembre han llegado entre 5 y 6
autobuses diarios a la ciudad pero este
jueves llegaron nueve unas 17.000
personas arribaron a Nueva York desde
abril para Adams esta gran afluencia de
migrantes abonda una crisis ya existente
una ciudad que se recupera de una
pandemia mundial en cursos se ve
desbordada por la crisis humanitaria
hecha por manos humanas hemos recibido
parte de la ayuda que hemos solicitado
la hemos recibido pero necesitamos más
estamos al borde del precipicio Wow
buses llenos de migrantes hacia
Washington Nueva York y Chicago aún así
el gobernador republicano de Texas dice
que seguirá haciéndolo continuaremos
transportando a los migrantes a Nueva
York DC Chicago para aliviar a nuestras
ciudades fronterizas hasta que bailen
haga su trabajo para asegurar la
frontera el gobernador de Florida el
republicano ron de santis llevó
recientemente en avión a un grupo de
unos 50 migrantes a la isla de Marta
Smith en Massachusetts los demócratas
acusan a abbott y a desantes de utilizar
a los migrantes como un arma política